es gibt neue bahnbrechende entwicklung
bei der elektromobilität und entgegen
allen unkenrufen verdrängt sie mehr und
mehr die verbrenner und bereits dieses
jahr führt sie die verkaufsstatistiken
an damit hatte wirklich niemand
gerechnet lange vor dem zulassungs
verbot für fahrzeuge mit benzin- oder
dieselmotor das heißt nichts gutes für
die konventionelle technik und die
traditionellen hersteller müssen sich
sputen volkswagen chef herbert diess
nennt immer wieder tesla als vorbild
werden jetzt alle autohersteller zu
tesla kopien oder werden sie dem
innovations- druck nicht standhalten
klicks um science im future bis dreimal
pro woche spannende science wie sie
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen und für alle die
händeringend darauf gewartet haben hier
ist es unter die einfach draufklicken
das ebook von meinem spiegel bestseller
tesla oder wie eine maske die
elektromobilität revolutioniert das gibt
es aber auch überall sonst wo wo es e
books gibt für alle digitalen unter euch
viel spaß beim lesen das model 3 hat es
geschafft es ist das meistverkaufte auto
nicht elektroauto auto insgesamt in
europa im september 2021 so die meldung
vor ein paar tagen wow der vw golf wurde
abgelöst und das von einem elektroauto
von einem vermeintlichen nischen
hersteller das dürfte für einige eine
schocknachricht gewesen sein und in
deutschland werden inzwischen mehr
elektroautos als diesel pkw abgesetzt
dass es wirklich beeindruckend und die
elektrofahrzeuge zeigen jetzt wie viele
vorteile sie in der realität haben und
welche innovationen da möglich sind
darüber jetzt mehr hier bei pixum
science in future sie wird kommen die
neue revolutionäre batterie von tesla
fünfmal mehr kapazität pro batterie und
nur noch die hälfte der kosten pro
kilowatt so ihre maske und auch
panasonic will im märz 2022 mit der
pilotproduktion beginnt im nächsten jahr
soll sie dann in die ersten fahrzeuge
eingebaut werden aber auch die
traditionellen hersteller warten
inzwischen mit fast jedem neuen fahrzeug
mit einer innovation auf der neue id 5
von volkswagen wird bidirektionales
laden beherrschen sprich er kann auch
wieder strom ins netz zurückspeisen wer
einen id 5 hat kann dessen batterie dann
zum beispiel bei einem stromausfall zur
stromversorgung nutzen die lade
geschwindigkeiten steigen und steigen
wobei man hier in der zukunft sehr genau
hinsehen sollte wie die batterien damit
zurechtkommen porsche hat die garantie
für die taipan batterie auf drei jahre
und 60.000 kilometer gesenkt wenn man
nicht bei langen standzeiten bestimmte
bedingungen einhält da scheint es
tatsächlich probleme zu geben aber dazu
später mal mehr inzwischen gibt es
elektrofahrzeuge mit einer
batteriespannung von 800 volt der jonigk
5 von hyundai bleibt nach
herstellerangaben in 18 minuten von 10
auf 80 prozent aber insgesamt fällt
autokunden auf dass die ladeleistung gar
nicht die rolle spielen weil die meisten
fahrten sowieso unter der maximalen
reichweite liegen und man lädt während
man termine hat oder etwas unternimmt
einkauft und so weiter spricht das laden
braucht die zeit die man zum ein- und
ausstecken des ladekabels benötigt es
ist also schneller als tanken und auf
langen strecken so ist es mir letztlich
mit einer 800 kilometer strecke ergangen
braucht man dann zum beispiel insgesamt
nur noch 40 minuten ladezeit bei 800
kilometern wer will denn auf so einer
strecke insgesamt weniger zeit mit
pausen zu bringen und selbst mit einem
id3 mit kleinem akku sind strecken bis
zu etwa 500 kilometer problemlos machbar
die lade frage ist also geklärt und das
angebot ist groß genug um ein
elektroauto zu finden das auch extrem
strecken komfortabel zurücklegen kann
und es gibt angebote mit wahnsinnigen
lage leistungen wie zum beispiel den
porsche die karten wahnsinnigen
fahrleistungen wie beim model s plate
von tesla sehr preiswerten elektro
fahrzeugen wie dem dacia spring 25.000
euro ohne förderung also etwa 11.000
euro mit eingerechnet förderung und
elektroautos benötigen weniger wartung
als verbrenner bei tesla gibt es nicht
mal wartungsheft ball kaum etwas gemacht
werden muss und sie halten länger ein
tesla model s laut einer internen quelle
voraussichtlich 800 1000 kilometer diese
haltbarkeit dürfte für alle elektro
fahrzeuge gelten weil es einfach viel
weniger verschleißteile gibt ohne
elektroautos sind innovativ wie pkw seit
langem nicht mehr und die hersteller
arbeiten fieberhaft an aktion ein tesla
arbeitet mit einem kleinen supercomputer
an bord und einer ziemlich
ausgeklügelten software und auch die
traditionellen hersteller wollen in
genau diese richtung im mercedes iq es
sind riesige displays verbaut die
allerdings noch mit alter technik
betrieben werden die gedenksekunde nach
jeder eingabe ist immer noch stark auf
volkswagen leidet darunter nachholbedarf
in einem id3 laufen drei rechner einer
für die mitte mit navigation
unterhaltung und so weiter für das
display hinter dem lenkrad das
inzwischen bei vw deutlich mehr als ein
tachometer ist und ein rechner für die
fahrzeugfunktionen dass das muss ist das
weiß man auch bei volkswagen und hat
einen entwicklungszentrum im silicon
valley aufgemacht und auch beim autonom
fahren ist volkswagen ganz vorne mit
dabei und hat sich zusammen mit ford an
einem unternehmen beteiligt das hier als
technologie für gilt ag i denn autonomes
fahren ist mit fahrzeugen ohne kupplung
getriebe verbrenner motor der auch mal
ausgeht viel einfacher zu realisieren
die elektromobilität ist eine der
schlüsseltechnologien für das autonome
fahren da sind sich alle einig in den
usa laufen zahlreiche pilotprojekte
doch sind die oft eher traurig mit
anzusehen wie zum beispiel ist gerade in
san francisco gestartet und steckt in
einer sackgasse und das im wahrsten
sinne des wortes zahlreiche mio
fahrzeuge landen irgendwann in einer
ganz bestimmten sackgasse und kommen
wohl selbstständig nicht mehr raus in
einem us sagt sowieso dass die
konkurrenz in einer sackgasse steckt und
nur sein system ohne leider und
radarsensoren allein mit kameras
deutlich besser funktioniert noch
arbeitet sein system nicht fehlerfrei
trotzdem reduziert das system von tesla
mit neuen versionen alle zwei wochen die
fehler und spricht es spricht einiges
dafür dass es 2022 eine nahezu
fehlerfreie version geben wird aber die
waren fortschritte werden offensichtlich
unter der haube gemacht gerade hat sich
volkswagen chef herbert diess wieder
darüber beschwert die schaffen ein auto
in zehn stunden und wir liegen bei über
30 stunden damit ist tesla gemeint und
auch das mit auch noch deutlich weniger
personal gerade hat tesla ein video zur
fertigung in china veröffentlicht das
sieht ganz anders aus als in einer
deutschen auto verrückt und dass das
ende der fahnenstange noch nicht
erreicht test als effizienz scheint
unerreichbar
mit seinen gigantischen kann das chassis
also der bau eines fahrzeugs in einem
teil gepresst werden damit wird laut
viele maske einer fertigungsstraße mit
300 robotern eingespart für das motto
bei wurde eine art ventil wärmepumpe
entwickelt die das temperaturmanagement
für klima und batterie übernimmt das
gibt es bei keinem anderen konkurrenz
fahrzeug nur wenn es nicht um innovation
sondern um qualität geht da haben die
deutschen autobauer meisten noch die
nase vorn wenn sie nicht gerade wir beim
id3 zu sparfüchsen werden doch dieses
alleinstellungsmerkmal ist mit einem
hohen preis erkauft denn die wahren
herrscher in den deutschen auto
verbringen sind die einkaufsabteilung
sie haben drei ziele sparen sparen und
sparen und tabak passieren dann so
furchtbare fehler wie vertragswidriges
abbestellen von chips das jetzt zur chip
krise führt weil kaum ein halbleiter
hersteller überhaupt noch lust hat diese
bauteile zu produzieren manchen chips
werden unter umständen nie wieder
hergestellt werden und diese sparpolitik
ist innovationsfeindlich da werden
lieber ein paar euro an einem bauteil
gesperrt als ein neues innovatives
einzusetzen wenn das nicht sehr bald
geändert wird haben die traditionellen
autohersteller hier wirklich schlechte
karten mehr über die elektromobilität
und tesla gibt es jetzt auch digital
meinem spiegel bestseller tesla oder
wieviele masse elektromobilität
revolutioniert gibt es jetzt auch als
ebook zum beispiel hier klicken für die
kindle version bei amazon oder ansonsten
überall wo es e books gibt viel spaß
beim lesen bis dann bleibt dran